t
elle est l amade en chantier ouvert par
françois hollande le redécoupage de la
france un compromis aussi délicat à
trouver que sur le pacte de
responsabilité la ministre de la réforme
de l'état de la décentralisation et de
la fonction publique et donc l'invitée
de preuves par 3 bonsoir marylise
lebranchu
merci d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec perrine
tarneaud ou de la fp avec thierry masure
ce soir et de dailymotion les
résistances s'exprime déjà si fortement
parmi les élus à qui on annonce donc la
simplification du coûteux millefeuille
territorial que l'on peut se demander si
cette réforme ne restera pas un voeu
pieux
non pas du tout d'abord il faut prendre
acte du succès d' du vote de la première
loi moi je suis toujours étonné que on
ne se félicite pas d'être passé d'un
texte qui pouvait être difficile à la
création des métropoles mais aussi au
grand paris que tout le monde attendait
depuis longtemps c'est fait mais la
suite sur cette impulsion donnée
président de la république a décidé non
seulement qu'il fallait continuer il
fallait monter une marche qui a redonné
une impulsion pour que l'on se retrouve
d'ici à là quelques mois puisque on
commencera au sénat où nous sommes on
est une loi qui dise clairement les
compétences de chacun qui fait quoi qui
referme un peu plus ses compétences
pense au développement économique et à
la formation professionnelle de
transport et ça va donc c'est un big
bang et certains se dit ça va faire
pschitt comme ça ça va faire pschitt on
est en train déjà décrire la loi j'ai
rencontré quelques parlementaires jeu
projet proposé à tous les groupes
d'aller les rencontrer moi ça peut faire
ce petit pas ce que vous avez dit je ne
vais pas manié la hache mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle l'outil vous
reste-t-il marylise lebranchu
pourquoi pas encore écouté les plus
hostiles de vos amis
c'est toi le scalpel ça va être mais
c'est la dentelle c'est trop facile
une loi pour qu'elle soit appliquée doit
être voté par le parlement nous ne
sommes pas en dictature et c'est tant
mieux donc pour avoir une loi votée par
le mois parlement il faut donner des
choses claires aux parlementaires c'est
quoi une compétence exclusive
comment on réduit le nombre de schémas
régionaux pour en faire un vrai schéma
du développement économique de
l'innovation et de la meilleure
attention au jargon attention non un
vrai schéma qui s'impose aux autres
collectivités territoriales comment le
citoyen en fait tu vas pouvoir ensuite
venir avec nous savoir où il s'adresse
pour tel ou tel type d'intervention
garde et de la solidarité parce que les
français sont attachés à la solidarité
et faire que nos communes avec nos
intercommunalités rationalise aussi en
moi l'envié d'écrire un sable déclinent
en sable sur un sujet assez complexe
quel est pour vous le nombre idéal de
région tu ne sais pas quel est pour vous
le nombre idéal de départements sans
doute beaucoup moins qu'aujourd'hui mais
je n'ai pas fait le calcul mouillez-vous
sais c'est pas mathématique comme bref
un bon mais quelle va être votre base de
réflexion est ce que ça va être les
économies à réaliser est ce que vous
avez fixé un objectif budgétaire non
j'ai pas d'objectif budgétaire mais la
résultante sera intéressant pour moi
j'ai un objectif c'est clarifier les
conséquent les compétences par d'accord
avec comme conséquence bien évidemment
des économies du côté de l'état du côté
des régions du côté des départs et là on
parle en milliards d'euros d'accords
l'idée c'est de supprimer les doublons
les compétences sans piment en arrêtant
de se regarder comme si on était une
horreur
alors même que rappelons-nous les landes
der allemand auquel il est toujours fait
différent références ont été obligés de
créer des espèces d'ânes ex deux länder
qui correspondent à peu près à nos
départements donc restons calmes sur les
comparaisons nous sommes nous ne sommes
pas si mal
à condition d'être plus clair plus
transparent aussi sur les compétences et
en particulier sur le développement
économique parce que c'est ça
qu'attendent les français
mais qu'on est aussi une compétence
solidarité de proximité parce que c'est
ça aussi qu'attendent les français en
difficulté etc enfin puisque nous
gardons notre nombre de communes nous
puissions impulser les fusions commune
merci sans rien changer il y aura bien
quand même des changements importants à
la clef la mini aura des fusions
d'intercommunalités il y aura des
fusions de départements
il y aura des fusions de région et une
fois vous pourrez pas le chiffre est
encore une fois cette première étape
passée par incitations et compris
financière parce que j'ai des élections
en 2015 et que je n'ai pas le droit de
diminuer le nombre de régions avant 2015
contenu des élections ensuite je me
donne entre 2015 et ce sera applicable
aux 2020 au moment des nouvelles
municipales à l'eau de rose auraient non
c'est pas du tout alors ça sera juste
après les élections régionales
vous allez avoir quelques régions en moi
une réorganisation pourquoi je ne
fusionne pas des régions tout de suite
parce que j'ai déjà des frontières
régionales et au lieu de fusionner deux
régions peut-être cafard que j'en coupe
donc c'est pas si facile à faire donc
henri durre de les disloquer certaines
ont droit les résistances qui
s'expriment parmi la population
cardy par exemple touche pas à ma
picardie mais on pourrait prendre
tellement d'exemples la seconde et ce
sont les élus qui freinent cette
attention la population est attachée y
compris à ces départements rappelez vous
du débat sur les plaques minéralogiques
comme on a été surpris
donc ce qu'il faut c'est être efficace
que m'a demandé le premier ministre ce
que m'avait demandé déjà quelques heures
avant le président arrêtez bush et qui
gère directement le dossier le dire mais
les impulsions en plus j'ai la chance
d'avoir un premier ministre est à
présent un public qui sont totalement ça
c'est votre chance 67 ans d'accord mais
aussi contre vous j'ai envie de dire
certains de vos amis politiques je le
disais le président de l'association des
régions de france le socialiste alain
rousset qui préside l'aquitaine dénonce
une vieille idée technocratique le
président sioniste suppression de
certains une région paralysant dresse le
président des départements claudy
lebreton socialiste également lui met en
garde contre l'exercice périlleux que
vous lancez oui c'est sûr que c'est
moins pire les risques je prends des
risques parce qu'il ya un moment donné
faut prendre des risques c'est vrai que
c'est pas facile à faire la tâche n'est
pas simple mais moi ce qui m'intéresse
ce moment c'est que avec un dossier qui
est compliqué je sorte avec une loi qui
soit claire pour les citoyens et je
pense que les citoyens veulent par
exemple s'ils sont en recherche d'emploi
ou quelqu'un de leur famille recherche
d'emploi
cannes est qu un qui soit responsable du
parcours qu'on a à faire
si une entreprise a besoin de formation
professionnelle il y en a qu'un qui sera
responsable de la formation dont on a
besoin
une entreprise qui veut des aides
directes au nord un quinze qui pourra
lui donner en revanche parfois un centre
de recherche pour être aidée aussi par
une métropole
d'accord c'est pas inintéressant donc
conjuguer des efforts quand il en a
besoin
avoir un interlocuteur unique quand il
n'est pas besoin de conjuguer des
efforts et avec tout ça on sera plus
serein plus apaisée et sans doute qu'on
reviendra aussi la fiscalité soit plus
économe
on sera plus économe on regardera la
fiscalité parce que je pense que ce qui
ne marche pas bien en france aujourd'hui
c'est l'inégalité entre les territoires
j'ai besoin de territoire fort métropole
région
j'ai besoin aussi que l'ensemble des
territoires de france occupent non
seulement des citoyens qui habitent mais
aussi de l'économie agricole agro
alimentaire par exemple pour reprendre
l'exemple
un grand show de sarry département de la
banlieue il faut les fusionner là vous
êtes d'accord les bancs de l'assemblée
nationale je me suis engagé à faire une
étude de faisabilité de cette fusion
donc si j'avais pas été d'accord et je
rappelle que c'est le premier ministre
m'avait donné l'autorisation de le faire
donc nous sommes entièrement d'accord
vous avez dit que votre arme
donc ça ne fera pas la hache mais ce
sera l'incitation financière donc un
bonus malus financiers c'est-à-dire la
carotte et le bâton
oui mais oui c'est toujours malheureux
de dire ça parce qu'on a l'impression
que les élus ne fonctionne que comme ça
je crois qu'en france il ferait aussi
parce que ça éviterait la tentation de
certains extrême qu'on réhabilite nos
élus ils sont pas laxistes ils sont pas
gaspilleurs ils font pas n'importe quoi
en revanche quand ils ont la compétence
sur tout et qu'un citoyen leur demande
les pousse à faire ceci ou cela ils le
font donc de douleur aussi les moyens de
pouvoir dire non
un certain nombre de cofinancement et
ceux qui demandent aujourd'hui que ce
soit plus clair parfois vont se
réveiller durement parce qu'untel ou
untel ne pourra plus les aider donc
donnons les moyens aux élus d'être
encore plus efficaces ils en on avait
moyen mais moi j'en ai envie faire qu'en
disent qu'ils en ont entrevu déjà une
maisonnée
est ce que vous diriez vous dites que
son panier speier est ce qu'ils ont pu
se rendre coupables de mauvaise gestion
quand on voit par exemple vous allez
pouvoir peut-être que confirmer ou
infirmer je ne sais pas l'explosion du
nombre de fonctionnaires territoriaux
dans les régions par exemple mais qui ne
sont pas tous justifiés pour les
transferts de compétences mais ça c'est
pas tout à fait certain parce qu'on en
oublie toujours que la gestion des tos a
obligé les régions à créer des services
d'accompagnement de personnes sensées
personnel non enseignant dénonciation
jean pierre est d'ailleurs en convient
aujourd'hui qu'on aurait pas dû confier
sa région parce qu'elle était d
administration de mission et pas de
gestion mais regardons aussi sont les
intercommunalités on me dit il ya plus
de personnel oui on s'est occupés
d'environnement s'en occupait pas avant
de déchets on s'est occupé aussi de
créer des services à la personne de
petite enfance de halte-garderie y
compris dans nos communes rurales
donc effectivement on a créé les
services publics et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de savoir que le
service public est utile que le service
public est efficace mais que le service
public n'est pas redondant parce qu'il
n'y a pas de doublon y compris avec les
services de l'état alors il ya un élu
qui est par ailleurs patron de partie
c'est jean françois copé lui pour
pauline des choses toutes simples on
supprime dit-il purement et simplement
les départements et on les fusionne avec
les régions et il propose d'en passer
par un référendum
voilà une solution simple mais c'est
simple et c'est simpliste je suis désolé
parce que on est là il dit il chiffre
les économies du même nom alors lui
chiffré milliards de milliards il ya une
grande étude que chiffres et amiens il
ya kpmg qui disent à coups de 6
milliards au début ça coûte plus cher au
début ce qui se passe c'est que quand on
chiffres pour les départements ont
chiffré leurs compétences obligatoires
et leurs compétences obligatoires par
exemple les départements aide une
commune ça ne suit pas disons d'un
fictif si l'école a brûlé le département
va aider la commune alors ça c'est pas
comptés dans la dépense de départements
ont dit si on supprime les départements
je supprime cette dépense non cela
transfert c'est pas la même chose donc
je pense qu'il faut être extrêmement
sérieux rigoureux et prénom est prudent
parce que regarder l'action sociale nos
personnes âgées aux personnes en
situation de handicap les personnes
éloignées de l'emploi
vous supprimez le département vous avez
deux hypothèques le transféreront comme
soi c'est l'état soit scellé commune une
commune qui a très peu de moyens
pourra-t-elle
rendent service à ces personnes âgées
non parce que je ne sera pas mutualiser
le département est une source de
solidarité soyons prudents mais efficace
c'est pas un tract politique c'est de
l'action politique à deux petites
questions on a beaucoup glosé sur le
virage de françois hollande même sur son
revirement se renie membres après sa
conférence de presse vous avez entendu
tous les commentaires est-ce que ça
n'est pas le cas sur le sujet qui nous
occupe marylise lebranchu puisque la
gauche revenait au pouvoir avait
supprimé la fusion lancé par nicolas
sarkozy des élus départementaux et
régionaux et là c'était une source
d'économie vous êtes marche arrière là
ont fusionné les élus mais je vous
rappelle ont fusionné pas les
institutions première étape
ah bon c'était déjà une première source
d'économie je ne sais pas parce que
quand vous fusionnez les élus locaux
obligés de reconstruire tous les tous
les hôtels de région pour accueillir
tous les élus de tous les départements
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas de place on
savait qu'on réduise et en réduisant
leur nombre
oui mais on était au-dessus 87 en
montagne on devait passer à 120 t
qu'alors autre chose non
et on fusionnait pas les institutions
l'idée c'est d'avoir quand c'est
possible y compris des fusions
d'institutions mais regardez l'alsace
c'est facile à dire tout ça on fait un
référendum on allait proposer la fusion
de la région des départements 10 à orly
les citoyens veulent des fusions
résultat ils ont voté contre alors donc
ça veut dire qu'il faut il ne faut plus
faire appel au peuple demain pour les
fusions de collectivités territoriales
de même rang les régions les
départements les communes ou les
intercommunalités ne suis pas favorable
effectivement au référendum mais je
pense qu'on peut partir aux élections
dangereux non c'est pas dangereux
moi je j'ai été un jour candidate à une
mairie j'ai voulu la fusion je me suis
présenté en disant je veux la fusion et
la commune d'à côté j'ai perdu parce que
la commune d'à côté à voter contre la
fusion mais je pense qu'on peut partir
dans une élection disons jeu je me
présente à tel niveau
je souhaite telle fusion alors
paradoxalement le peuple dira mme
lagarde
paradoxe encore vous aviez rétabli c'est
pas vieux à se remettre de sa clause de
compétence générale qui donne en fait
aux collectivités locales balaie les
mêmes pouvoirs quoi elles font ce
qu'elles veulent un donc hélas la guerre
établi à la vous nous dites aujourd'hui
faut clarifier mais pourquoi ce
changement de pied mais je pense que
séoul s'est remis à culpa coup on a
envie d'entendre
parce que moi j'ai écrit ça dans la
mission d'ambert
y'a quelques temps elle était interviewé
omd est ce que vous êtes favorable à la
clause de compétence générale c'était
non donc la véritable et on est partis
tel constat de défiance totale entre les
états et enfin 3 le gouvernement et les
élus défiance tels que on a vu beaucoup
de collectivités territoriales se
replier le président de la république je
rétabli la confiance je regarde avec
vous comment on peut faire
je tire maintenant je suis en 2014 je
tire le son du vote de la première loi
le vote de la première loi me montre que
sur les métropoles
vous êtes plutôt favorable a par exemple
sur paris une disparition des
départements
vous m'avez demandé au 1er janvier 2017
les conventions obligatoire je rappelle
entre les départements et les métropoles
donc vous parlement de france vous avez
fait avancer beaucoup le dossier mois
président de la république ou premier
ministre à côté puisqu'ils ont la même
avis je vous propose de continuer sur
cette lancée et de renforcer la
régionalisation d'accord et d'avoir
moins de compétences partagées et comme
nous avons déjà créé la conférence
territoriale de l'action publique est un
lieu de discussion et bien nous avons
l'outil pour avancer nous avons donc
avancé et l'énergie on vous entend
marylise lebranchu l on va voir
maintenant comment vous allez vous y
prendre pour faire des économies dans la
fonction publique et là ce sont plus les
élus ce sont les syndicats que vous
affrontez une certaine manière avant
d'accueillir thierry masure de l' agence
france-presse le point sur un chantier
social délicat sinon explosif avec
mounir souci j'estime qu'il est possible
de faire des économies nombreuses tout
en préservant notre modèle social
fort de cette conviction françois
hollande espère économiser 50 milliards
d'euros d'ici la fin de son quinquennat
une cure d'amaigrissement qui aura des
conséquences sur la condition des cinq
millions et demi de fonctionnaires leurs
salaires et retraites représentent près
de 40% des dépenses publiques
le gouvernement est face à une équation
compliquée comment économiser sans
baisser les salaires tout en créant des
postes dans l'éducation et la sécurité
il ne reste plus beaucoup de marge de
manoeuvre pour parvenir à cet objectif
c'est à dire qu'il faut au gouvernement
soit continuer
gel du point d'indicé qui a été initiée
en 2010 ou bien continuer de rogner sur
les mesures catégorielles
les primes des fonctionnaires marylise
lebranchu évoque une éventuelle fin du
gel des salaires avant 2017
une mesure coûteuse la hausse d'un point
d'indicé représente les 800 millions
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires
depuis l'arrivée de françois hollande à
l'elysée les syndicats négocient dans un
climat apaisé avec leur ministre de
tutelle mais il commence à perdre
patience
le dialogue social s'il n'y a pas de
grain à moudre issia pas derrière
d'augmentation de salaire et de majin
des effectifs ça ne suffira pas pour
calmer les fonctionnaires et son
ras-le-bol augmentera encore aux puces à
la fin du mois de janvier
tout simplement parce que pour la
première fois le salaire des
fonctionnaires va baisser
une exaspération dangereuse dans cet
électorat traditionnellement favorable à
la gauche
en cette année électorale beaucoup
pourraient être tentés par le front de
gauche où l'abstention
à moins que le gouvernement annonce une
mesure choc le deal qui avait été
proposé par le passé c'était sans doute
moins de fonctionnaires mais mieux payés
et sans doute une voix qui à la fois
permettra de contenter les
fonctionnaires en place et à la fois de
mener à bien cette réforme de l'état que
tout le monde appelle de ses voeux avant
une éventuelle sanction dans les yeux en
le ras-le-bol des fonctionnaires
s'exprimera dans la rue avec une grève à
l'appel de la cgt programmée le 6
février prochain
voilà thierry masure de l'agencé france
presse et avec nos territoires vos
questions donc sur ces sujets multiples
relevant de la fonction publique à la
ministre on est en plein dans
l'actualité l'a donc la première chose
que j'ai envie de vous demander demain
matin il ya le premier conseil
stratégique de la dépense publique qui
se tient autour de françois hollande
donc c'est le début des travaux publics
alors est ce que c'est la fonction
publique qui va être et les faux les
fonctionnaires notamment qui vont se
retrouver sur le grill non d'abord c'est
vrai que par rapport à lens un
gouvernement moins trente mille postes
par an et on est à - 0
l'idée était de renforcer l'éducation
nationale parce qu'on a un vrai
challenge devant nous la police la
justice et l'emploi
et puis bien évidemment hamas constante
ça veut dire de supprimer des postes
c'est vrai et je comprends la colère des
syndicats dans d'autres secteurs la
défense qui a donné
beaucoup de postes merci la forteresse
comme on dit économie et finances a
participé et quelques-uns ici ou là donc
on a sérié ce nombre de postes à
supprimer aujourd'hui la feuille de
route est différente on continue
effectivement la trajectoire et
syndicats vous disent on est à l'os
thierry le paon le disais hier dans le
monde
on est à loos alors comment va peser sur
l'administration territoriale de l'état
c'est à dire sur les territoires c'est
là que le premier ministre me demande de
faire et fort avec l'ensemble de mes
collègues c'est ce dont on va discuter
comment avoir peut-être un peu moins en
centrale et plus sur les témoins termes
d'effectifs la voir venir donner un
chiffre
en termes d'effectifs je venais je ne
suis pas favorable à donner quand même
on a envie de savoir les effectifs ce
sera combien j'anticipe jamais sur les
dossiers qui sont pas terminées mais si
vous savez que fait pas de politique
fiction mais je veux plus de monde on
est en train de faire une analyse
territoire par territoire y aura moins
une faune du ministère par ministère
je ne sais pas s'il y aura moins de
fonctionnaires mais il y aura peut-être
moins au niveau de l'état sur certains
postes plus haut niveau des
collectivités territoriales si on
transfère des compétences centre est
idiot de garder à nouveau des doublons
mais je voudrais dire parce que c'est
important
moi je comprends ce que des
fonctionnaires 4 angel n'y a pas
beaucoup de deux personnes salariées du
privé qui ont 4 ans vous reconnaissez
qu'ils ont perdu du pouvoir d'achat est
en revanche moi j'ai proposé et le
premier ministre a accepté
on a augmenté les catégories c et ses
dires les plus petits salaires
je pense que les plus hauts salaires
s'en sortent parce que ils ont un peu
plus de chance mais il n'en méritait
bien évidemment mais c'était sur les
petits salaires et en particulier dans
la fonction publique territoriale tout
en ayant conscience d'avoir fait aussi
plus de dépenses publiques pour les
collectivités territoriales
mais on a pris d'abord l'aspect petit
salaire maintenant on dépose 2014-2015
fr comment parce qu' est-ce que vous
avez continué ce gel pour la cinquième
année et continuer à faire des économies
parce que les 50 milliards il faut bien
les trouver quelque part je ne sais tu
pas l'hypothèse qui sera choisie mais je
vous rappelle et tout le monde veut
l'oublier parce que ces techniques mais
c'est pour moi hautement politique qu'on
a commandé un point zéro
n'ont connu que bernard pêcheur on pose
toutes les carrières de la fonction
publique sur la table on regarde comment
faire fonctionner mieux tout ça avec des
parcours professionnels avec des
passerelles entre les collectivités
territoriales avec l'amélioration des
conditions de travail y compris pour nos
seniors puisque on augmente la durée du
travail donc on prend en compte nos
seniors on a un chantier de 18 mois ça
ne se fait pas à coude annonce ça se
fait métier fonctions par courriel vous
et que vous allez comme ça jouer à saute
mouton au dessus des journées d'action
des syndicats y en a une par exemple au
6 février
bon si yvon des îles vont décrire des
puits en continu conduit les premiers
ministres ont l'intention de faire comme
s'il n'entendait rien du tout le sens
attentif non seulement à la qualité de
la fonction publique à nos
fonctionnaires mais aussi à leurs
conditions de vie alors vous pouvez
désamorcer cette grève jusqu à un moment
donné il faudra qu'on ait une vraie
discussion mais avec les syndicats je
suis désolé pas avec vous et pas ici
pour dire est ce que c'est un peu de
poil à 10 est ce que c'est encore un peu
plus cette aile catégorie est-ce que je
mets plus sur les parcours
professionnels
in fine et quand on aura fini le mandat
ad en 2017 sur l'ensemble des parcours
professionnels
on aura propres pour les carrières on
aura progressé pour nos fonctionnaires
il est hors de question de régresser
sinon on va les perdre
or on a besoin de fonctionnaires pour le
service public et de fonctionnaires de
qualité donc c'est tout allait rouler
compliqué
j'ai un travail de dialogue social
complexe mais nos fonctionnaires
demandent quoi de la reconnaissance ils
n'ont pas eu souvent d'être mieux
traitée par les médias --y compris
parfois aussi par le chef de l'état
puisque le chef de l'état a dit que
l'état était trop lourd trop chers n'ont
pas dit les fonctionnaires sont roland
les temps l'état et les fonctionnaires
ont pris pour eux non mais moi je le
prends pour chacun quitte en fonction le
prend pour soi
est ce que ce que me demande moi le
président la république par exemple
quand je fais le dis le nous une fois
pour les entreprises avec pierre
moscovici
quand on fait les simplifications pour
l'usager quand il rentre et qui sait
qu'il aura rendez-vous qui n'aura
absolument pas attendre ce qui n'est pas
le cas dans certaines entreprises
privées
quand on fait des simplifications de cet
ordre là on est moins lourd on est plus
efficace et une file et on sera moins
cher puisqu'on va économiser du temps
cadre donc
était ce matin au secrétariat général de
la modernisation de l'action publique
qui dit comment on va mieux utiliser le
numérique comment on va réagir et une
nouvelle culture
tout ça va fonctionner mais j'entends
que les fonctionnaires eux par rapport à
leurs mandants et puis il ya des
élections à la fin de l'année à
l'intérieur de notre fonction publique
pour la représentativité et bien ils ont
envie aussi d'avoir comme disait
l'intervenant tout à l'heure interrogés
du grain à moudre
est-ce qu'ils sont pas un petit peu
désorienté finalement les fonctionnaires
est ce que serait pas été plus simple de
dire eh ben le gel d'un fonctionnaire
sur deux
le gel du un fonctionnaire sur deux
n'est pas remplacé
lorsqu'il part en retraite eh bien on
poursuit cette mesure parce que de toute
façon pourra pas faire autrement parce
que c'est comme ça ce n'était pas juste
parce que c'est efficace sur certains
territoires vous n'aviez plus personne
en termes de contrôle de
l'agroalimentaire pour l'export par
exemple une personne et dans ce cas là
vous pouvez perdre des marchés donc la
france ne s'y retrouvent pas plus
personne pour des problèmes de santé
plus personne pour la sécurité routière
attention il faut qu on ait un équilibre
sur les territoires dans moi j'ai à
travailler dur mais qui est passionnant
c'est comment effectivement on a sur les
territoires l'état garant l'état
protecteur mais l'état qui permet le
redressement économique
comment on a peut être moins dans
certaines fonctions qui ne sont plus
utiles peut-être mais comment on fait
tout ça en améliorant des parcours
professionnels de nos fonctionnaires qui
sont peut-être un petit peu archaïque
parce que le fonctionnaire en font ils à
temps il sait que dans cinq ans il aura
t l'avancement et que dans x années le
rater l'eau ils fassent radin gradins
échelon tout ça n'est pas suffisamment
percutant et moi je pense qu'on est
capable de faire beaucoup en remettant
toutes les carrières sur la table et en
travaillant je l' ai rappelé tout à
l'heure mais c'est important sur nos
fonctionnaires seniors quand un
fonctionnaire territorial court derrière
la benne et qu'il a passé 60 ans
l'efficacité de l'action publique n'est
pas au rendez vous ni pour lui parce
qu'on ne les respecte pas ni pour le
service rendu on a des tas de choses à
penser
les surveillants de la pénitentiaire
partent très tôt est ce qu'il pourrait
faire autre chose après ils sont
intéressés à ce qu'on va faire
est ce qu'il faut faire toujours la même
la même barrière entre ce qu'on appelle
les actifs la police il se souvient d'un
pénitencier alors essentielle
sion qui pourrait travailler plus
longtemps il y en a qui me demandent à
travailler le seul vraiment pas bons
mais ils n'ont pas de passerelle et
qu'est ce qu'ils font dans ces cas là et
bien quitte la police pour entrer dans
le privé comme surveillants sont mal
payés bref pas heureux comment on rend
nos carrières plus attractive comment
créer des passerelles qui permettent aux
fonctionnaires d'être efficace et
éventuellement de travailler plus
longtemps s'ils sont dans une famille
recomposée avec des enfants jeunes bref
il ya un tas de travaux à faire pour nos
fonctionnaires et dans l'efficacité et
dans l'économie
les fonctionnaires n'ont pas envie qu'on
dépense plus pour eux ils ont envie
d'être reconnus aujourd'hui reconnu
comme un vecteur fort de la république
française c'est eux qui portent des
valeurs républicaines c'est eux qui
portent la partialité
c'est eux qui portent la loyauté
fonctionnaires c'est un exercice
sacerdotale et les fonctionnaires moi je
pense que c'est autre chose on n'est pas
fonctionnaire j'avais c'est pas un
emploi ordinaire vous devez garantir les
valeurs républicaines
y compris quand vous sortez de votre
boulot vous est encore fonctionnaire
vous êtes encore en présentant dans
république c'est pas rien et je pense
que ça doit être dit reconnu le premier
ministre et a présenté ses voeux à m
jeudi prochain et j'espère et j'espère
que j'en suis persuadé leur dira il ya
il ya un vrai sujet de reconnaissance de
ce qui s'est passé
la calinothérapie fonctionnaires gardent
leur feuille de paie parce que pas
seulement dans la mesure où j'ai
monsieur engagé à poser toutes les
questions sans tabou avec les
fonctionnaires dans le dialogue social
j'espère qu'on aboutira à quelque chose
qui peut être passera par des conflits
je ne je ne pense pas que nos relations
pouvoir signer un accord à quel horizon
sur les carrières
moi j'avais 10 18 mois on a commencé en
janvier
ces deux c'est difficile il fera qu on
est d accord d'étape parce que
effectivement ils vont demander sans
doute des étapes on va voir avec eux
quelle étape sont souhaitées mais je
reste persuadé qu'en même que les
fonctionnaires les moins payés ont bien
reçu qu'on ait augmenté les catégories c
je sais qu'il ya des problèmes
maintenant sur les bas des catégories
juste au dessus on a resserré est jeune
on a ce qu'il faut je suis pas moins
plafonner la rémunération supérieure
d'étape qui situerait alors que leur rue
s'embrassent à commencer par le 6
février la rue s'embrasser c'est une
grande phrase
un conflit de l'aide de la fonction
publique ne me fera bien évidemment pas
plaisir c'est évident je ne sais pas si
vous êtes démunis pour le désamorcer je
ne suis pas certaine de ça parce que
dans le dialogue social j'ai en face de
moi des gens extrêmement responsables
qui veulent dire à un moment donné au
peuple français aux citoyens français
pardonnez moi qui veux dire aux citoyens
français on est là et aujourd'hui c'est
nous qui payons la rigueur moi je sais
ce que je leur décourager ça c'est pas
c'est pas bon non plus pour l'efficacité
de l'état opaque fonctionnaires seraient
découragés et vous savez quand à
longueur d'antenne de lecture ils
entendent parler qu'ils sont une entrave
en fait à la bonne santé des
entrepreneurs par exemple et que les
entrepreneurs vers le werder demander
aide pour trouver un terrain à m
pour l'assainissement aide pour les
déchets être pour la localisation est
pour l'export elle pour les
infrastructures
quelquefois ils sont découragés et sont
découragés parce que quand il demande à
l'entretenir mais pourquoi vous voulez
vous pensez que je suis inutile
entrepreneurs libres pas vous mais voilà
une espèce d'imagerie collective
la fonction publique serait inutile non
la fonction publique est utile au
développement de la france et au
redressement de la france à condition
qu'on sait sur quelle mission
et comment voilà pourquoi c'est un
challenge difficile
oui sa deuxième langue officielle non
mais c'est vrai la réforme de l'état
mais c'était bien c'était pas la réforme
de 2000 feuilles territorial l'action
publique du 21e siècle personne ne parle
plus ravis que moi merci thierry masure
une question encore sur la cgt en a cité
thierry le paon
qui appelle donc à cette mobilisation
des fonctionnaires et qui est considère
que le premier ministre aujourd'hui de
la france c'est pierre gattaz
c'est sans doute une boutade c'est comme
si je disais moi le chef de tous les
syndicats c'est thierry pour jean
thierry saniez que lui non je crois que
de temps en temps ça c'est une boutade à
il argumenté dit non simplement fait la
politique du medef
ça c'est quand même pas vrai parce que
si le gouvernement faisait la politique
du medef en particulier sur ce que tous
viennent tout ce que je viens de dire
la fonction publique ce serait beaucoup
plus simple ils m'ont supprime rien sur
deux trois bars et puis on parlerait on
passerait à l'étape suivante je pense
que c'est plus complexe et plus
difficile que ça allait perrine tarneaud
de public sénat arrive maintenant pour
la troisième partie de cette émission
marylise lebranchu où nous parlerons de
la gauche du ps apparemment sans voix
d'ailleurs comme votre grande amie
martine aubry marie brémaud au sein de
la majorité en ce moment on ne parle
plus de virages mais bien d'accélération
social démocrate comme si l'économie de
l'offre avait toujours été à l'ordre du
jour pour les socialistes
même l'ailé gauche du ps se fait très
discrète la gauche du parti peut ne pas
être content mais n'a pas grand chose à
proposer en charge la politique qui
suivrait sa blonde d'un field de
d'insuffler de l'argent des notes dans
l'économie n'est pas suffisante pour
remédier aux problèmes structurels de
l'économie française les plus à gauche
tente de faire bonne figure et de sauver
la face c'est le cas notamment des
proches de martine aubry
j'accorderai ma confiance au
gouvernement mais je ne la corde raide
dans la confiance que si il ya des
contreparties sérieuses et si on
continue à mener une politique de
justice martine aubry qui ne partagent
pas les vues libérales du président de
la république lui exprime ses désaccords
mais là aussi en toute discrétion
vous savez il discute très régulièrement
ils le font loin des caméras parce que
martine aubry candidate aux municipales
à lille j'ai le travail dans son club
renaissance à réfléchir à des idées
nouvelles et puis le président de la
république il est président de la
république donc chacun dans son couloir
chacun avec ses responsabilités chacun
avec son devoir d'avoir des résultats
et ça les empêche pas ensuite de
s'échanger très directement et très
franchement sur ce qui va et ce qui ne
va pas mais ça il souhaite pas le faire
devant les caméras les couloirs
différents qui ne se rejoignent pas
souvent à chacun son chemin
bonsoir madame la ministre est donc raté
pour le retour de martine aubry au plan
national
est-ce que c'est raté pour son retour au
plan national ce virage social démocrate
merci devrait jamais parti c'est ce qui
m'étonne le plus on me dit elle est plus
là au niveau national si maintenant elle
a plus beaucoup là elle est plus locale
parce qu'elle vous voit pas par les
médias nationaux
il est pas forcément elle est très
présente au niveau local n'at il pas
forcément utile de parler aux médias
nationaux pour avoir toujours eu une
influence politique
dire que quand on rencontre le président
de la république le premier ministre des
ministres
quand on râle sur telle mesure quand on
est en cours à acheter l'autre quand on
fait aussi
moi j'ai bien aimé cette respiration
qu'elle nous a offerte sur le prendre
soin justement c'est quoi l'action
publique dans le prendre soin de nos
citoyens que par le caire et l'a jamais
parti mais quoi concrètement la caisse
qu'elle a connue récemment comme
inflexion on aimerait savoir pourquoi
voulez-vous que être en politique ce
soit être dans un gouvernement il n'y a
que trente et quelques personnes s'étant
japon coup c'est déjà beaucoup et puis
certains
en politique il ya beaucoup plus de gens
de que ça je pense que chacun peut être
utile là où il est ce qui est important
c'est pas qu'elle soit là sur votre
plateau peut-être non non pour sa
maladie ont plaisir à mais nous on pense
effectivement à matignon comme le dit
michel ou à son retour il ya un problème
ils sont avait pas deux à quoi sert un
remaniement
voilà mais moi j'en sais rien dire je
suis pas dans la tête du président la
république
je ne sais pas quel camp il y aura un
remaniement s'ils en ont un
keller et puisque le tournant social des
mauvais score de françois hollande elle
est compatible avec le positionnement
politique de martine aubry françois
hollande a tenu et c'était intéressant
dans les entretiens qu'on a en ce moment
parce que il ya aussi du travail
c'est à cette notion de contrepartie
c'est-à-dire d' équilibre aujourd'hui on
a quoi on a une crise et une sortie de
crise parce que la crise a commencé en
2008 qui est très lourde dans une sortie
de crise vous avez toujours
l'agroalimentaire après vous avez le
bras team enfin vous connaissez ça par
coeur donc on sait que ça va globalement
jusqu'en 2016 quand on lit les bonnes
études n'est pas ceux qui clament donc
on sait qu'à ça donc il s'engage et
prend au mot le patronat français qui
n'arrête pas de dire si nous ont des
bars moins vite que les autres parce que
on paye trop de cotisations manco pmoi
une cotisation ils ont déjà quelques
pour cent - je rappelle donc ils vont
être transformés sans doute on verra le
résultat
beaucoup sont donnés mais il fallait pas
d'objectif chiffré de la part du chef de
l'état peut importe je dire qu'on les
prend au mot en disant vous vous dis que
si leur filtre à porter la
responsabilité
non le chômage non pas du tout on est
pro je fais pas partie de la réalité du
chômage d'entrepreneurs je vous dis coni
si moi je vais te parler contrepartie
j'ai le patronat dit si vous faites un
geste et en particulier sur la branche
famille et d'ailleurs il faut noter que
la cgt ou fo ont fait ce même cette même
type de composition
rappelons-nous et bien nous créerons des
emplois banco on y va sauf que en face
il faudra effectivement créer des
emplois et que le citoyen français aura
aussi le royaume martine aubry pardon
aura aussi tout moyen de réfléchir à ce
qu'on donne en terme de baisse de
cotisations et aux résultats
est ce que ces contreparties à leurs
vis-à-vis du medef vis-à-vis du patronat
c'est ce qui va réussir
à bâillonner à obtenir la gauche du ps
autour de ce pacte de responsabilité
je pense que nul n'est bayonnais j'ai
entendu j'avais vu beaucoup de voix
discordantes à un vote de confiance
aviez un petit peu d'ordre
oui mais ce que je sens aujourd'hui ce
que je sais oui c'est que tout à chacun
qui est sur les territoires rencontre
une population qui veut que ça redémarre
sire que la france se redresse et c'est
vrai qu'un cent sans mettre à bas les
services publics par exemple ceux qui
m'ont travail sans mettre à bas y
compris nos collectivités territoriales
pour que l'accès à la culture par
exemple continue à permettre aux gens de
s'émanciper en pleine crise économique
mais ne demandent en même temps te
retrouver une france industrielle de
retrouver une france en europe et de
retrouver une france dans le monde
or on sait tous donc c'est le réalisme
du terrain avec un terrain qui
l'emportent
c'est de l'analyse de la situation et la
volonté de faire face à une période
difficile mais on sait tous par exemple
que la chine qui a été longtemps une
usine à produire du monde entier va
commencer à acheter
est ce qu'on est prêt nous répond est ce
qu'on est prêt à créer de la valeur
ajoutée en france est ce qu'on est prêt
à voir l'innovation que d'autres pays
vont nous demander ça c'est sur la table
donc à l'accord soit ce qu'on a dit
l'équivalent de la branche famille ça a
été annoncé un accord
une bonne organisation des collectivités
territoriales pour que l'aide à
l'innovation à la recherche
développement à la transformation en
nurserie d'entreprise de jean pain ce
soit au rendez vous et puis une analyse
et contreparties mais un service public
qui continue à exister c'est le modèle
français
dire qu'on est en train de sauver un
modèle way avec une politique de l'offre
c'est difficile c'est effectivement une
ligne difficile mais c'est une ligne
mais ça il faudrait il veut il faudrait
empêcher effectivement la défection à
gauche est ce que l'autre contrepartie
pour la gauche du parti socialiste ce
serait une petite baisse des impôts pour
les ménages en 2015
c'est pas une petite baisse des impôts
pour les ménages c est comme moi comment
je privilégie les catégories les
moins favorisés de mon pays sert comment
je garde un système social dead
important qui n'existe pas dans beaucoup
de pays
comment effectivement sur l'impôt je
fais attention à ce qu'ils ne sont en
dessous des 2000 euros par mois par
exemple avec deux enfants qu'ils ont
vraiment payer l impôt vert filtre pas
de volonté de faire baisser les impôts
pour les ménages en 2015
je ne peux pas demander aux ménages et
en particulier aux plus faibles d'entre
eux d'être ceux qui vont permettre la
baisse des cotisations dont j'aurais de
parler
donc c'est ça le la difficulté de ce
gouvernement c'est ça son châle en vient
on appelait mais quelle marge de
manoeuvre
on n'a pris aucun chemin facile on
appris que des chemins difficiles mais
parce que la période est ainsi et que la
france dans l'eau je voudrais juste dire
une chose
quant aux citoyens nous peint ils sont
aussi intéressés par ce que le président
de la république a obtenu un smic en
allemagne et l'accord et le spd de
martine aubry en juillet 2011
souvenez-vous martine aubry signons avec
sigmar gabriel ça c'est à fait important
nous citoyens demandent que pour la
directive des travailleurs détachés on
arrête de faire de la concurrence
déloyale et on lui ben loulou il vous
demande d'augmenter le smic aussi en
france c'est ce qui l'a demandé mais
c'est pas c'est pas à rejeter a priori
il ya des moments où il faut savoir
regarder ensemble c'est difficile mais
on y arrivera on y arrivera parce que la
france va se redresser et c'est ça qui
est important à dire aux français quand
on emprunte un chien je maintiens fils
il en est sûr de réussir à 100%
non il faudra il faut que woods ait
jamais le chemin est difficile
moi je j'ai tous les matins une part de
doute parce que celui qui est sûr
d'avoir raison à 100 % ne peut pas être
un politique ou alors les apolitiques
qui peut être dangereux en revanche il a
toujours mais si on pouvait enfin parler
de la france avec un langage de
confiance je peux vous dire qu y compris
les tpe les pme les petites boîtes ne se
porterait pas de la même façon c'est lui
c'est le langage de défiance dans son
pays
on appelle ça du bashing
c'est la défiance par rapport à son
propre pays qui amplifie la crise moi je
pense que le président de la république
a raison avec son premier ministre au
bout de 18 mois au bout de 18 mois moi
j'ai toujours eu l'impression d'être sur
scène nina bon peut-être que vous m'avez
pas écouté
vous n'avez pas écouté certains voyaient
alors vu reprocher d'avoir perdu deux
ans non mais vous avez une opposition
mois l'opposition j'ai entendu hurler en
disant on ne parlait pas d'héritage en
février 2012 nous n'étions pas au
pouvoir depuis 2002 ça faisait dix ans
il nous disait si on est en difficulté
c'est à cause de la gauche donc
peut-être que la voix y compris de
l'opposition pourrait devenir
raisonnables ce serait intéressant on
aurait un vrai débat quelques petites
questions en politique donc jean-louis
borloo il va soutenir le pacte de
responsabilité mais il ne votera pas la
confiance au gouvernement vous regretté
qu'il n'aille pas au bout de sa logique
jean louis borloo il fait ce qu'il veut
franchement je vais pas lui demander de
l'aide ou quelques bons centres seront
utiles il ya des défections à gauche
c'est pas comme ça il faut faire et dire
on met sur la table la question on
mettra un document la meilleure aide
document il n'est pas encore sur la
table à jean-louis borloo de prendre sa
décision d'accor et bayrou lui la rater
le virage social démocrate de françois
hollande il est parti trop tôt à droite
j'ai lu ça partout je pense qu'il a fait
un choix c'est le sien mais est ce que
les français attendent vraiment que
bayrou soit un peu plus ici ou un peu
plus là ils ont envie que ça fonctionne
mais je pense que si ça fonctionne
peut-être que bayrou viendra mais bon
c'est quand même pas moi je laime
beaucoup de garçons mais pendant ce
temps à faire ce que j'aime bien
françois bayrou mais c'est pas mon sujet
j'aime bien le rencontrer il est
intéressant d'entre elles comme nous
journalistes vous avez senti lors de sa
conférence de presse mardi dernier que
françois hollande déjà en campagne pour
2010 est en campagne pour 2017 j'ai pas
senti ça mais je les trouvais bien en
sondant sa détermination et ça c'est
extrêmement agréable pour un ministre
que d'avoir et j'ai trouvé la même chose
ce premier ministe pour vous j'ai trouvé
qu'ils ont tous les deux ont été une
marge de plus cirque avec des étapes
difficiles sont derrière nous maintenant
on voit là je sens on monte les marches
et j'ai moi envie de monter les marches
avec eux une derrière eux parce que
derrière vous l'avez sentiment là on est
et on a beaucoup observé aussi par
rapport à ces tombes en personnel jeu
sam de l'état à perenco marin assez bas
mais ce qu'il est temps de travail sur
la situation personnelle
enfin mon sujet à beaucoup de ses amis
qui demande un jeune ancien maire depuis
là encore plus intéressant vous parler
de ma situation personnelle chez moi
tout va bien avec moi c'est ce que vous
souhaitez aussi pour france ô mais
chacun il faut faire attention donc il
faut faire attention aussi à la presse
internationale qui est très très dur
encore cette semaine justement sur
françois hollande notamment aux états
unis où il va aller bientôt enfin la
chance c'est d'avoir malgré tout j'ai
envie de dire parce qu'effectivement je
pense que c'est pas simple pour lui en
tant que personne mais moi j'ai trouvé
un président serein et déterminé faisant
justement fi de ce qui est
de ce que sont ces premières occupations
personnelles moi je trouve que c'est
plutôt mal et je lui demande de rester
comme ça après pour sa vie personnelle
ça le regarde ce qu'est ce que vous
répondez à henri guaino qui déclarait ce
matin sur europe 1 françois hollande
monte tout ment tout le temps et surtout
c'est peut-être en règle et nous non et
frais demandés j'ai pas qu'ils nous
illustre son propos qui effaça joli
bouquin je vais pas sur la technique des
moissons ce serait intéressant
j'avais envie de vous demander en
dernière question sur l'île et gs qui
était utile de rouvrir ce débat
aujourd'hui je regrette comment dire
la réaction des bas moi ça me paraissait
normal j'ai envie de dire presque
naturel alors que le naturel n'existe
pas en droit qu'on enlève cette clause
qui a pu encombrer le raisonnement et
qui n'est plus cet océan de détresse
voilà c'est pas mon regret d'ailleurs
c'est qu'il est trop d'avortements jeu
c'est le même regret que celui de
marisol touraine où donner la tête
aujourd'hui à l'eau belkacem c'est que
on n'est pas assez bon et pas assez tôt
en particulier avec des plus jeunes sur
les situations de contraception pour m
réception mais je pense qu'il ya
certaines fractures qu'on met en jeu
vous entendez dans le pays notamment au
moment du texte sur le mariage ne sera
pas être hypocrite
pendant longtemps moi j'ai la chance
d'être plus âgée que vous c'est une
jambe et d'avoir vécu les premiers
entretiens des femmes qui demandait une
ivg c'était très dur et je pense que
comme souvent c'était en face des femmes
elles n'ont pas voulu continuer sur
cette espèce de concept de détresse qui
est difficile à partager
en quoi l'arrivée d'un enfant peut
provoquer une détresse chez lui n'est
pas celle où on est
donc voilà je crois qu'à un moment donné
le respect de l'individu forcé la loi il
a forcé la loi menant dans une semaine
ce sera fini sauf en espagne où certains
s'inspirent rechercher les responsables
en france toujours et de tentations
extrémistes y compris là c'est une
tentation d'extrémisme il ya fracture et
les sociétés en fonction des opinions
souvent religieuses et je pense que
fracturé les sociétés en fonction des
opinions religieuses c'est chercher une
forme d'extrémisme ou d'intégrer
et c'est ouvrir la porte à 210 mois
l'épiscopat qui a soutenu les
manifestations
je pense que l'épiscopat français a
raison de dire qu'il est contre
l'avortement parce que c'est son
engagement religieux mais il n'a pas
sonné mais de là à aller manifester en
tant que tel dehors c'est autre chose je
pense que la liberté concernant
l'arrivée j'ai vu et j'ai la liberté des
femmes n'est pas une liberté d'opinion
c'est une liberté personnelle liberté de
son corps merci marylise lebranchu merci
perrine merci à tous bon soir la semaine
prochaine notre invité sera brice
hortefeux a très vite